in this video we will study about the
human into crying system before
beginning if you are new to this channel
make sure to click on the subscribe
button below to get all the upcoming
Skype education videos and also if you
find the content of this channel helpful
you can now support Matt's simplified on
patreon.com
for the price of a coffee cup that will
allow me to make more free education
videos like this all the links are in
the description below and for more
information watch till the end of this
video the human endocrine system
consists of a number of glands located
all over the body that secrete hormones
and regulate various functions of the
body
modern endocrinology originated in 20th
century upon the works of a French
physiologist Cloud Bernard who made a
key observation that humans have a
constant internal environment which he
called milieu interior which is
preserved by various systems of human
physiology including the nervous system
the immune system and a set of glands
that secrete chemical messengers known
as hormones the human body needs control
over its cells tissues and various
processes in the body so that it can
function in an orderly and stable way
which makes the vital functions like
growth development and reproduction
possible now this control is mostly
provided by three systems in the body
the immune system the nervous system and
the endocrine system now the nervous
system is in charge or control of
various body processes that happen
rather fast like movement breathing etc
and while the immune system controls
body's actions related to infections and
damage the endocrine system in general
is in charge of the body processes that
happen rather slowly for example how
fast the height of a person should
increase or maintenance of a constant
level of electrolytes and ions in the
blood or body's metabolic rate and
various other numerous processes that we
will talk about later the human
integrated system consists of the
following glands which are located all
over the human body we have the thyroid
gland in the neck which secretes
important thyroid hormones which affect
nearly all the cells of the body and
maintain a proper metabolism of the body
cells behind the thyroid gland we have
these four yellow paratha
glands which secrete important hormone
parathormone this hormone regulates the
calcium and vitamin D metabolism in the
body above the kidneys we have the two
important adrenal glands which secrete a
variety of hormones that affect the
metabolism of glucose electrolytes as
well as they secrete the various
catecholamine hormones the adrenaline
and noradrenaline we have the pancreas
which secretes the important hormone
insulin which is important for the
metabolism of glucose fats as well as
proteins the reproductive hormone
producing glands are very important and
the differ in the two sexes in the
females we have the ovaries which
produce important sex hormones the
estrogen and progesterone and in males
we have the testes which produce
testosterone in the end we will study
the glands that control the secretion of
all these glands which are the pituitary
and the thalamus which are located
inside the brain
now let's look at a typical model of how
most of these endocrine system works so
we have various endocrine glands which
are able to sense about various
processes of the body these glands
secrete hormones which act as chemical
messengers that are then distributed to
whole of the body through the
bloodstream to initiate a specific
effect to put this into context let's
take the example of the pancreas the
pancreas for example secretes one of the
very important hormones the insulin the
pancreas has a rich blood supply through
which it can sense the concentration of
the glucose in the blood whenever we eat
the concentration of glucose in the
blood Rises which is detected by the
pancreas upon which it releases the
hormone insulin this hormone activates
most of the cells of the body to take up
the extra glucose in the blood which
stabilizes the normal glucose
concentration in the blood and most of
the hormones produced by the human
endocrine system are of two types
we have the protein hormones and we have
the steroid hormones while most of them
are the protein hormones there are only
few hormones which are of the steroid
nature which include hormones like
luteinizing hormone the follicle
stimulating hormone and testosterone now
these hormones when secreted by a gland
are carried to the bloodstream and
circulated in whole of the body now some
hormones affect only a specific part of
function of the body for example
testosterone which affects only the
gonads as well as the secondary sexual
characteristics of the human cells which
include thyroid hormones which act on
almost every cell of the body to
regulate the cell metabolism these
hormones exert their actions on the
cells by binding to specific receptors
now these receptors may be located on
the cell membrane they may be present
inside the cell cytoplasm or even inside
the cell nucleus once these hormones
attached to their receptors they exert
their effect to different mechanisms
which lead to the effect of the hormone
one important mechanism are the ion
channel receptors in this case the
binding of hormone to the receptor
causes opening or closing of one or more
types of ion channels that regulates the
entry or exit of one type of ions in the
cell another very common type of
receptor
are the enzyme-linked or the g-protein
coupled receptors in this case when the
hormone binds to the receptor it causes
the activation of many enzymes in the
cell which exert the effect of the
hormone we also have gene linked hormone
receptors where binding of the hormone
to its receptor in the nucleus causes
activation or deactivation of a
transcription factor of a gene in DNA
example of this is the steroid hormones
will increase the transcription of genes
which are responsible for increased
protein synthesis in the cell so first
of all we will take a look at the
thyroid gland the thyroid gland is
located immediately below the larynx and
it is one of the largest of all
endocrine glands weighing about 15 to 20
grams the thyroid gland secretes two
important hormones the tea for the
thyroxine and a t3 or the
triiodothyronine 93% of all the
secretion of the thyroid gland is the t4
and only 7% of the secretion is d3
thyroid hormones require iodine for
their synthesis in a dose of 1 milligram
per week these hormones are protein
hormones that bind to their receptors
which are mostly located in the nucleus
or the cytoplasm of the cell
after that the thyroid hormones have
hundreds of effects on cells like
increase in the number of mitochondria
of the cell increase in the carbohydrate
and fat metabolism and increased
activity of the various ion channels of
the cell membrane it has many systemic
effects like increased cardiac output
increased heart rate and increased CNS
activity in short we can say that the
thyroid hormones are important in a way
that they regulate the basic cell
metabolism and activity which ultimately
affects the body as a whole now the
second gland that we will talk about is
the parathyroid gland it is called
parathyroid gland because it is located
just adjacent to the thyroid gland or
behind it we have four parathyroid
glands one behind each of the upper and
lower poles of thyroid the parathyroid
gland has a vital function of regulation
of a constant concentration of calcium
and phosphate in the body it does so by
releasing a hormone known as parrot
hormone which mainly acts on born
intestines and kidneys through
and assigns it regulates how much of the
calcium should be absorbed in the body
through the kidneys it can regulate how
much should be excreted and since bones
are a large reservoir of calcium and
phosphate it can use that to increase or
decrease the calcium and phosphate
concentration of the blood the next
endocrine organ that we will briefly
discuss are the adrenals now these
glands are called adrenals because they
are present just adjacent to the kidneys
sometimes also known as the suprarenal
since they are located above the kidneys
now if it like a look at the cut section
of the adrenal glands we can see that it
is made up of different sections on the
outer side we have the adrenal cortex
and at the central part known as the
adrenal medulla and both of these parts
secrete different types of hormones
now the adrenal cortex has three layers
or zones which are zona glomerulosa
which is the outermost layer we have the
zona fasciculata which is in the middle
and then in the inside we have the zona
reticularis these layers secrete
different hormones and these can be
remembered by a simple mnemonic the GFR
which stands for these layers
now the outermost layer the zona
glomerulosa produces the hormone
aldosterone which is a mineralocorticoid
elicited on mainly acts on the kidneys
to maintain a constant level of sodium
potassium and other ions as well as
fluid balance of the body the zona
fasciculata the middle layer of the
original cortex mainly synthesizes
cortisol which is a glucocorticoid
cortisol is essential for life as it has
permissive actions on multiple organ
systems as well as metabolic processes
throughout the body
now cortisol is essential for your body
to have a proper stress response it is
essential for your body to have a proper
metabolism of glucose fat as well as
proteins it is essential for important
normal BP regulation and normal immune
system regulation now the innermost
layer is the zona reticularis which
secretes androgenic hormones like the
dehydroepiandrosterone which are
important for the development of
secondary sexual characteristics in
pathetic nervous system it releases the
catecholamines epinephrine and
norepinephrine into the general
circulation it is activated when the
sympathetic nervous system is activated
and it is essential for the classic
flight-or-fight response of the body so
this was the first video on the series
on endocrinology make sure to watch the
second video on the series the link will
be in the description below in the
second video we will discuss about the
rest of the endocrine glands and we will
also talk about the control of these
endocrine glands by hypothalamus and the
pituitary gland
guys thank you so much for watching this
video if you found this video and all
the other free educational videos on
this channel helpful you can now support
meThe simplified on patreon calm for
literally the price for coffee cup this
will allow me to fund my work and make
more videos like this and will also
unlock some cool patreon only exclusive
content like behind-the-scenes of these
videos upcoming videos early
notifications and exclusive flash cards
and handouts make sure to subscribe us
on YouTube for all the upcoming videos
and also make sure to follow us on
Instagram and Facebook for flash
notifications and much more